I'm feeling a little more optimistic in
the little not a lot I got lots of
options we're in a save room and I got
this like exit I got a key and there's
these two red doors so I feel like
that's pretty good so my question is
Mike I got not a lot of ammo I got nine
shotgun shells and thirty-five handgun
rounds I got like really heavy ammo that
I don't think you want me to use like
twelve magnums and twenty freeze rounds
or I have five gunpowder aids I could
make some more handgun rounds so what
should I do
I also have a mine thrower with 18 that
I could bring doesn't know what's coming
up though I know that's why I'm tempted
to bring it just in case doesn't bring
the handgun I don't know you're not you
got a few doors around the save room to
go check out I would just feel it out
first I don't want to pick up stays in
my throat all right okay so let's go go
go
how far do you think I am in the game I
just feel like I've been around for so
long well it's a puzzle [ __ ]
why why do I keep getting these I don't
want these
nobody wants blue herbs alright so I
assume I can't walk in front of that
steam and I'll get hurt that seems like
a reasonable thought right
probably yeah press that button maybe or
something I don't know elevator so I
think that will hurt me
yeah that didn't help one to the left
maybe
[Music]
so I just need to get that console is
that what's happening right yeah
they're weird this is a weird room it is
a weird room there's no reason to have
pipes only have steam coming out of one
of the other can you just not have any
of them have steam coming out this is a
poorly designed room
nice there we go this controls the power
to the safety system it's set to standby
mode will you push the switch yes
power has been supplied to the safety
system no ok good I thought it was the
Nemesis like I hate I hate the Nemesis
so much like I have fear about him all
the time and it's just breaking me down
Mike what did that just do I thought
that did it
I was I think oh [ __ ] I hope I don't
have to redo that puzzle
I assumed it'd still be fine
I thought thought it turned on the
security for something I'm need you get
your head in the game you're my only
friend here Oh God
I just live in fear of death all the
time I don't think I've sorry I I heard
it you can hear it I'm not crazy
here there's another one
just go in guess oh yeah I just like
that something is aam be
[Music]
[Music]
more disks are those blue words you have
yes
there's too many I'm hurt
yes no I don't have room for all this
okay
all right I need to come back you can
just combine the blue and green one why
why not you can combine a red one with
them too
oh right you're right you're right it
still will give me an empty space yeah
well get the other green one combined
with the blue one or lose it I could
just eat it cuz I'm on caution what do
you want that sure why can't I pick this
up I'm gonna get hurt nice I don't even
know what you're doing in here I'm sure
I picked up that thing I'm sure there's
other stuff in here too don't you think
couldn't pick that thing up all right so
I think there's another guy in here um
let me think there's another red door so
I should kill that thing
God died okay so that didn't do what I
thought it did
okay I might be a little stuck the
treatment room lock what's that
I'm a little stuck there's anything else
to do in that steam room baby there's
that there's an elevator in there let me
get rid of some loose stuff my god I got
more health I was getting bad I got this
facility key and I don't know what to do
with it
I got the system disk and I don't know
what to do with it
some puzzles serious puzzles going on
was there something over there
you check those lockers
I will check them on the way back see
way what did this do press it again is
there something on the other side I feel
like there's something inside wait don't
oppress that don't write that
why just don't press it press this the
green thing again see what's a safety
system that's it okay so yeah maybe you
have to show off that fake speed right
now
okay okay potentially I don't know okay
Wow there you go well it's off right now
but
oh come on
I think it was just to get up there
I think that's it of where to turn on
the system
interesting there's a couple door Jian
to card the libraries facility key
should work I'm one of them yeah the rep
yeah right
I must have missed one so I did okay I
got it
yeah okay so the one with all the
zombies there's a door in here okay run
out cuz you word had your inventory full
or something
well the zombies were also coming after
me this is a big room I should just kill
them shouldn't I yeah no probably we say
that but I don't need your shock I'm
sorry I'll just take out a couple get up
[ __ ] I think it's a map on the wall
next you as well
whoo that's really good whoo you want
that no yes dead factory that sounds do
great big hermano okay so I want to turn
around
and I want to go that way oh he was fast
that's not fast enough that was a weird
angle and I didn't appreciate it
oh my in an elevator mm-hmm there's
another door in their room I should I do
that instead yeah probably
gotta speak up this is a huge area I can
take another hit
dear that
I hear it I hear you you son of a [ __ ]
oh I will take those do
oh I don't know can I hit that barrel
without getting hurt and got it what can
I get
can I get hurt yeah I think so
shape back up I don't know I think I'll
change the camera angle
there's like a liquor caught in the
machine cleaner oh you're in danger [ __ ]
oh wait right right right right I climb
down as well I don't or shoot down I
think I can yeah shoot down at it I
don't even know if you need to here down
midair shot geez cost me all my bullets
come out of shotgun shells all right so
to go to the left and just scope it out
there seems to the filter is completely
blocked a liquid with a nasty odor is
leaking out
das dead people and then just just check
it out and then take a left
okay it's not going too bad it's a nice
neutral
I've got a water sample
oh it's a safe room do you think I
should save ya really gotten that far
like I know but you don't want to redo
all this I do a little bit more
um I don't feel like I have enough ammo
to continue with how much [ __ ] has been
hitting the fan I'm not really sure what
else I can do
yeah but this doesn't feel very good I
got two shotgun shells and 19 bullets
this doesn't feel like a lot like I
bring the mines not much
check them out cuz I got to go downtown
here I obviously feel like my insta you
told me to explore the upper floor first
where the elevator take you like where'd
you get off the elevator
the first floor so it took me down I
guess but I don't even know if I can get
anywhere else
because I was I was in this room with
all the Psalms and I ran into this
elevator that's read like I do have a
key but if it's not for that then what
am i doing I don't know I don't know
yeah you guess you could check out down
here let's go downtown me [ __ ] saving it
might be a good idea
what's your wall over here it looks like
panels and stuff
what wall their red lights and [ __ ]
that's where I got the sample
there's a pink ribbons right in front
this typewriter you might as well save
not just seals the deal for me you're
gonna give me free ink ribbons I'm gonna
save
[Music]
[Music]
now I have 11 ink ribbons I feel pretty
good
we hoarded them
yeah oh mercy oh the mother lode mark
your yeah oh my god it's just a room of
dreams I can't carry any more sweet
sweet dreams
I have it
[Music]
don't know which wave range will you
adjust oh no I was supposed to be paying
attention okay do you think I'll be able
to come back here or do you think I
should just put all these things in my
safe box now cuz I'm kinda into my safe
box now in case like you know some
[ __ ] goes down it probably won't but
we are playing nemesis I just don't feel
good about it
so I work [ __ ] on slack it is the end of
the year here alright so those gun power
bees definitely reassure me do you think
I need the facility key and the system
disk I'm gonna put them down for now
so that I can hoard Morse tooth and then
I will come I will come back for it
yeah after Game of the Year was
announced I was like my biggest hurrah
and at this point like I'm just like
screaming for Christmas vacation because
I like I just been putting in a lot of
hours and I just like think I need a
like a mental day or something yeah
basically like the whole crew works like
stupid shifts for the last two weeks to
make sure everything works for the last
you know game of the year stuff and it
can really push you just kind of like I
think I want to play a video game for
fun
and not like edit it after it sounds
really nice sounds like a real treat I'm
just gonna run around this table and
make sure there's nothing else I can
pick up
beakers I'd love this
all right so let's do this puzzle so
something's happening right now and I
don't know what it is do you know what
this puzzle means Mike I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'd really wouldn't be I know I
need your help
I don't know what this puzzle means
okay so here's the puzzle
all right hey
[Music]
I guess
oh I see okay this is weird yeah so okay
here I'll show you let's check again so
what it's saying is is there's two
layers that should be one layer there
should be three layers I should be zero
layers there should be two layers that
should be one layer this should be one
layer this should be okay I see okay so
oh wait so this is what it is
wait what do you want it to be you want
to be the top yeah okay so I got it yeah
so we want to move one move see to the
right first cuz it looks like based on
what though
like let's think about it look I mean
I'm assuming it's gonna start over on
this side you know I mean like one
second just give a second I just wanna
think so you want it to be what's on top
right yes oh [ __ ] okay nevermind sorry
I'm thinking backwards
[Music]
you're gonna have to move be antsy at
least yeah cuz look you want these
filled up so hey looks fine remove them
left or right though that's what I want
you to understand I know but just to at
least to start off we can get rid of
this tall stacker here so just try to
see your B to the right I would say C
sounds fine can you fill up that
all right so now we can do another check
so now I would do B to the right okay no
see right here you want all three
stacked so you got to move please
we need a three stuck here to the movie
or the right so I think at some point we
need to read a you'll probably do a
there right twice to get that three
stack oh you got the three second right
now okay so what don't we have check it
now just to see
so that's empty you don't want that to
be empty so yeah there's one and we want
this one to not know you want that to be
still fully stack
so if we moved one over that would solve
that yes yes which one
possibly it wouldn't fix it though
that's the problem
you need 1.2 go in [ __ ] I'm like
confused you want 1.2 go here maybe a
yeah it's not really gonna try a and see
what happens and you can always go left
if it doesn't look right well just do it
no I'm saying for it to go left
Oh left so like sorry no but then that
won't be there I know it's not gonna fix
it yeah wait that that wait did I go too
far yeah that's still not working it is
not working oh no no go right twice no
right now right three times
well that will go back to where it was
no no no go right again hold on let me
see this right that should it doesn't
work geez so I try right one more time
one more time
oh I see we're saying wait no go left
again for no no I'm sorry I'm dumb okay
right with a and then right with B see
if that works
right like twice would be no that won't
sell anything it's see that you got a
change B is all messed up now that now
go see to the left
well you so you'd want C to be to the
right maybe
I like see there I'm gonna need to like
solve the beginning of this puzzle on
mean empty space here so I think a has
to move yeah okay that's what we're
doing wrong we should focus on the empty
spots that would be way easier there's
too many stacks focus on the empty spots
you need you know I mean so you have to
move a there can't be anything there uh
here on my logic like there literally
can't be anything in these spots just
try to line those up that would be way
easier than this okay
wait could do that worked oh sorry keep
trying a because a is definitely
more maybe what's it oh I see
that looks no that's that's gotta be
empty oh right
that's weird
what a [ __ ] this is it right there so a
is good so that has to be that way yeah
good idea
the C looks fine he's fine he's got a
move be like to the right a couple times
cool or to the left right would be
faster there's a gap right there I think
one more time should be good yeah check
it that was smart
[ __ ] it's probably just be [ __ ] be oh
I should be a stack in the middle I
think a has to be there that was the
literal only combination that works
right that was smart so it's just about
moving be to the right place
no it's got to be see to because that's
got to be gonna make - right there -
we're in the middle got it okay yeah
you're right
oh [ __ ]
try be right
no I think that's right no there's
nothing here right I think um Oh for the
double stack
all right so for that that's a double
stock that's double stack that can't
happen so this can't be right
got it this is an interesting puzzle and
I actually like it
okay
all right listen
I think it's this and I'm gonna give you
a couple reasons why this is one and I
already got one
this is a trip stack and that's in that
line this is a double this is a trip
stack and it's there and it's empty
there so I think it's C now I think it
was right no no I think it's I think B
is in the zone so I'm gonna see you 1 to
the right ok nice
wait what does that mean
is it open an area is that what it did I
thought that means the lock seems to
have been released
okay so now I can go back up these
stairs now the question is this we did
it again where we saved before a puzzle
so if white died I'm gonna have to redo
this goddamn puzzle which sucks
whatever that one wasn't once we figured
out what we needed to look for that was
easy
jeez that was an interesting one
all right so I got a lot more a and B so
my question to you is what do you want
me to do with them like I got a lot I
got one two three four five six seven
eight days eight eight and three B's so
we should do something with them so I'm
pretty low and I have 20 freeze rounds
so my question is should I make thirty
freeze rounds oh I see were singing like
is it worth making basic ammo right now
I mean I'm out of basic ammo yeah
essentially and I need to deal with 20
freeze rounds is really good like I
think it takes ten to kill an emesis fee
I want to fight him no because I had ten
left I might died for an hour I missed a
couple times though I'd like I have
eight days like I could get some basic
basic [ __ ] ammo and be okay like what
shock on her hand wait you just got
shotgun rounds I did I use those I used
okay so you can use one of those you
don't have a C well I could make a see I
have a and B you got twelve hit and
magnum rounds and you like I hate freeze
rounds I think you're fine like making I
have thermal shot I have three B's so I
can combine and be a mixie it's very
easy to do I wouldn't be averse to you
making like six shotgun shells that
would help you through the next couple
of rooms cuz like my fear is if I don't
if I don't have those shotgun shells
I'll have to use the freeze rounds or a
magnum to take out in these animals jump
fine to do I'll [ __ ] use one I also
got these grenade rounds probably just
use my grenade launcher
like I'm probably good actually what do
you think I would say I really wouldn't
blame you for doing like doing a BU with
every learning tool in getting shotgun
shells because there's a bunch of
zombies the room at the top of the
elevator I don't know how like was pop
him with a grenade I don't know if it's
gonna kill all them them I don't know I
honestly don't yeah I've never used them
against regular zombies yeah it's up to
you like it just sucks that you saved
was now out yeah it was really good
soon all right I'm gonna do both and
I'll just all just the consequences are
mine
if you guys don't like it sorry I'm not
very good at this game here we go
alright so I shouldn't save again we've
decided that cuz all he did was do that
puzzle no I don't say that puzzle really
wasn't as bad as we made it probably
save again like 10-15 minutes about an
hour episode 15 kind of got like cheese
oh that workout you missed it no [ __ ]
my heard it [ __ ] that [ __ ] up they got
they got uh like jigged on the stairs
and they couldn't do anything and that's
why I said I said I think you're like
able to cheese it right here well no he
was like touching me and couldn't attack
me that's great
but I thought I fixed it
but I thought I'd fixed it
I guess I'm confused because I thought I
thought that we just cleaned the water I
thought that's what I just accomplished
I'm not I'm not entirely sure what I did
wrong there
all right so there's gonna be a fight
damn what the [ __ ] are you serious [ __ ]
you don't know what fast for a while
alright so this should be fine okay okay
okay you don't think I can go much
further
whoa
Nicholi now the other Russian guy I made
since I'll be the only one from those
but really happened I'll have more
bargaining power when it comes to
discussing my bonus then why kill me I'm
not on their payroll the shooter calls
to you the amount is modest but there is
a reward to be claimed upon the
confirmation of your death just like the
Nemesis oh damn
Oh what shooting at me
ah dang
his blood is orange what go over there
check it out came from the ceiling
what killed him what we're not gonna
talk about this I have the system disk
what that's really confusing
look I'm bathing in his blood ah that's
what you get that was weird that was
weird xenon and I present a switch which
one big red one this one yeah yeah you
know I got that okay that was weird
what kill them am I gonna fight it
because I need some serious like ammo no
no no no
what's happening
No No yeah can you run away
[Music]
happily it gives you like one of those
choices
uh okay let's talk about this I'm
severely ill equipped to handle this
situation yeah I don't think you're
actually supposed to be fighting him
like a normal with that like [ __ ] is
filling then what should I do
yeah you don't have enough to kill it No
I only have one health kit
that acid was not something he enjoyed
[Music]
go on go on
I'm dead aren't I
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
all right
no you're not dead but you're not you're
gonna have to do like a telephone pole
method whoo I do like those valves how
do I do it
just shoot when he's near them truth
about for acid oh that didn't go well
use your hand got that website handgun I
heard you I just decided against it
[Music]
they're not spray anything it didn't
look like it did it
Oh
I'd say just ride it out if you die then
we could just call it up so you know I
was trying I was going for the handle no
I know didn't work out
so on caution what do you think don't
heal yeah spread away I'm trying to line
up your shot on this
you're not it's not light here did not
now it's
it's supposed to alright we'll get out
of there that's not working it's
supposed to auto yeah here we are
training it out there you go
yeah he dodged the right idea you're
just not really trying I don't think
well going
it's unfair I didn't know I was [ __ ]
fighting my nemesis
that's annoying that's probably it no
you got it
I'm very hurt whoa
the trash stopped it trying to get this
last one wait until he's near it though
or like right before it crap take like a
second to start coming out that's all I
have this thing saw his other arms off
back up
oh [ __ ] damn that might have killed him
too I know at least you know how you
want to call it an episode do that next
time it's up to you now that we know
what do you have to do now kind of want
to do it what do you have to do well we
have to redo that puzzle that's fine
cuz we're pretty close damn I didn't
know I was gonna fight him I would have
brought way more health
I thought I had it unlocked Mike
it's really disappointing [ __ ]
nemesis he's always on my butt I hate
that guy alright this sucks
alright nineteen shoot it's a lot easier
to kill the nemesis when there's things
that you can use against him
let's just burn through this part now
that we know how to do it should go
pretty quickly in theory beautiful
theory
oh [ __ ] I have to remake everything you
not to do it now that forgot about that
it's such a bummer like I didn't know it
was in here so I saved and then later on
we're like we like realized that it was
super easy
yeah all right so there's only one
option for a so let's just deal with
that first
yeah why'd it just redo that oh it cuz
that's what it wants and
there you go
wait what is it different no I think no
no sorry
dude do we solve it you're good you just
have to move to see I think we actually
might be all right
No
[Music]
No
okay I got it I've got it I've got it
come go doobie yep
go on move B yep to the right like twice
yeah one more time
that won't work
this is a trip stack I know wait just go
right again one more time
[Music]
one tomorrow
was that it
no nevermind don't look more don't look
at it like that should solve it see
we'll fix the ones you need to look at
where you need trip stacks and make sure
that has that has yellows in it I think
you should go more to the right would be
and then what oh I see we're standing it
on the triple stack there now yeah like
you should be focusing on trip stacks
for beads like it needs to have nothing
nothing in the holes and trips where
trips are supposed to be for be at least
and then sees need to be the same like
focus on trip stacks
[Music]
that right there it was a note that
right there
that's not yeah one more the right there
you got boom got it
no penis I understand you keep saying
that one more the right
[Music]
doesn't this need a line yeah
maybe bees not right or try bringing
that big one to the right a couple more
time like try see right one more Barisan
that once more twice that
no because that's a triple stack there I
don't maybe he's not I don't think these
right
so
haters
no that's not it
so that way wait wait sorry go be the
left right there
it couldn't be that
and then we'll move see
we did once more to the right
that is actually I think that adds it
yeah I think it is job
No
did I just do it okay just figure out a
and then no I got a I've got an out
that's good I remember what it looked
like oh my god go a the left not right
it was faster going left
yeah it said do you want to adjust it
and I said no I don't want to adjust it
[ __ ] you
honestly [ __ ] this stupid [ __ ] game
that makes me so much for this and call
it an episode no use it god now go yet
BTS go the right once I think twice
maybe
yeah choice or once we keep going right
on the right track I think that's it no
no no go left again the left once and
then be use gonna go left
oh my god we didn't learn it all three
ways okay hold up
no honey she won't write with yellow
maybe that that looks pretty good it's
got dubs with the dub stacks and trips
in the trip stacks yeah this looks right
oh that's annoying you have to go into
one of the letters to check I see what
you did yeah
so I was like no I don't want to check
anymore I want to tell it I think that
was it did I do it you know
go
dude there's something wrong you might
not be right I don't think it's right I
think you need I think go up to be sorry
and then move it to the right like twice
I can't believe in this puzzle yeah this
is indicative of my entire that's
experience this game okay now she's like
every time I think I'm doing okay to the
left
no no that's trip
just keep going
boom there you go
we bet your [ __ ] but I'm saving but I
still think I should try to kill the
nemesis I'm just saving I don't give a
[ __ ] if we save three times I don't want
to do it again and like [ __ ] them
that's a hard puzzle I wanted to do that
[ __ ] again
[ __ ] [ __ ] Oh what wait you're not
gonna get that I I don't have any room
dude
I am capped all right well no he's not
up yet saver
well like I'm gonna go back and get that
stuff now yeah I might as well but
that's why I wanted to save cuz I was
like oh man I actually did it I did do a
lot and I need those shotgun shells I
think right yeah did we talk about that
I feel like I need those shotgun shells
yeah probably
[Music]
I'm coming back for Yuki don't you worry
don't you worry your pretty little head
about it
[Music]
that's such a huge
like this the saving is becoming really
punishing the fact that like I lose all
this stuff I think that was like 15
minutes to like redo this so it's like
not a simple thing anymore
okay okay cool cool cool now you're
saving now I'm gonna save and I'm gonna
kill the nemesis and I'm gonna saving us
okay I know it sounds like a lot you're
killin em sis would be worth not doing
again I don't want to do this stupid-ass
do-or-die one shot that I'm gonna like
give you an ultimatum because I feel
like when you think there's not a chance
you stop trying so just the one chance
this episode you get to fight the
nemesis okay I accept now I remember
we actually did make bullets and I
needed them so I'm gonna make them again
okay but hand gun I would suggest Oh
instead yeah maybe I should make one of
each because I really did use them yeah
one of these but don't like try not to
shotgun shells in the valves you can
help it yeah also remember had a time it
you got to shoot it not when he's right
next to it yet because if you do it too
early he'll step back and avoid it
you're too late he's gonna hit you and
it takes like two seconds to fully come
out and shoot so you got to do it like
when he's like again like the second and
a half two seconds away right okay it's
very imprecise bossfight I'm this game
is great for a lot of reasons but I'm
also not impressed for a lot of reasons
I'm I'm just broken at this point like
my nemesis being the villain the whole
time is great though okay he's he's the
worst and I hate him dearly but I I feel
like this has just really taken a toll
um specifically like just like my
mentality has just been ruined like I
just feel like I can't go on I mean here
we are all right is this where they jump
at me no okay I made that up
no that was the park under the park oh
the Deimos because I thought they were
more to come at me in at the stairs
cheese net oh come on there's another
one after the top of the stairs here
so slow where is he hate those things
alright well I found some more shotgun
shells under here that we missed before
so that worked out okay and then I fight
him in here is that right I think so
no yeah you got to go up to the oh we
have to then Nicolai seen again yeah I
know I told you we did a lot here's
dumped Russian accent I wish we could
just like rush through it happen again
it's inconsistent well it's consistent
it happened for a second time
illogical maybe yeah although this whole
game is a really based on logic those
are pretty good reflexes actually
dodging bullets
she can't dodge the nemesis Pentacles
when it comes to discussing blue eyes
that tripping top brings out her eyes it
really does the amount is modest these
kneepads in case I fall on a steam
that's not a bad plan hey talk about to
my aunt Jeffrey I understand what your
problem is we all have problems esteem
you're not the only one I'll be right
back sir sir
yeah this is the scene of such a red
herring thinking sometime
[Music]
all right all right I'm gonna come back
all right come on let's make this happen
all right okay we're back baby
what'd you save after I got all the
items and we made bullets you'd still
have to redo that cutscene and that's
about it and if I kill him right back to
a saving I only brought to help it's a
bit of a gamble I do I understand
[Music]
[Music]
if only it happened that fast right okay
so should I do the one that's like right
next to me that's like it's not really I
think it's probably me it's just really
hard oh man I'm already [ __ ] the good
news is once you hit him once I think
he's an arm like that's so [ __ ] I don't
know I don't know what to tell you I
mean I did it
you were there trying to do that I
should I do it I don't want to kill me
yeah I guess but try to do the art to
dodge right now I think it's your only
chance at the moment
once you feel and reload your handgun
why I can't are to dodge I'm already I'm
facing him oh you need time it okay all
right so good he's got one less harm I
get [ __ ] I thought I thought it would
work out that was mistake on my part I
have I mean I have regrets stop whipping
me you [ __ ] you up
yeah run just like to that side nice
that's so [ __ ]
yeah I wouldn't even worry about those
let's try this maybe you're too close to
it there you go
yes
that angles Network yo it's not it's not
working I knew it I don't know what to
say that do a different angle I tried to
dodge him actually went worse than the
last time that's super annoying I am
calling it rule will come back in I've
had a bad day
this is like three pretty much negative
episodes in ER I'm sorry alright that's
it we'll do some more over break it's a
lot guys
be back I'll be back
maybe a little less depressed